So my visual politic and Migos, Tanzania is in the news for two reasons. Yeah,
that's right. You have this Tanzania and there's one good reason.
And then there's one bad one.
The good news is this East African country is holding presidential and
parliamentary elections when October 28th and election,
that could end the ring of John [inaudible] president of the country since he
won elections in 2015.
But the bad news is that his presidency has been a steamroller over the rights
and freedoms that previously existed in Tanzania.
We are talking about extreme violence against opponents,
strong political oppression,
and limited freedom of expression for anything other than praise and
commendations for the current president. So as you might be able to imagine,
this is something that makes us doubt that we are going to see fair and true
elections.
It seems likely that there'll be rigged in some way while mega fooly is in
power. I'm sorry to say, but the truth is that in this case we are pessimistic.
And although we don't know what will happen in the near future,
we can pretty much imagine it.
The case.
What we do know is that the political instability caused by mega foully has also
had economic consequences and take note, because this is important. Yes, yes.
Some of you may be thinking Tanzania, but what you seem to run. I mean, come on.
What did you expect? But here you may be skeptical, but we visual politic.
We actually like to be optimistic and I'm aware that it's 20,
20 and optimism has been canceled, but we do try.
And the truth is that in this case, there are many reasons to be optimistic.
The 21st century started well for Tanzania.
With many years of strong economic growth,
the country was situated in the band of countries that make up the so-called new
African awakening.
We've already talked about in other videos about Ethiopia of Rwanda. However,
since Micah fully came to power,
it seems not Tanzania is not doing so well anymore.
It's all gone downhill so badly, but the IMF questions,
the economic growth figures provided by the government.
So the question today is why has the political situation in Tanzania
deteriorated so much are the suspicions about the figures provided by the
government justified today on visual politic,
we are going to answer these questions,
but first let's take a look at some history.
African socialism.
They have heard of places like Dar ES Salaam, Tonga, Tanganyika, or Zanzibar.
So I suggest you take note because the historical nuances are very interesting.
Again with Tanzania is the union of two States that had once been independent to
tango Yuca and Zanzibar Tanga.
Yoga is the name of one of the most important leaks in the world,
lik Tanganyika. But when we referred the Republic of [inaudible],
we mean the current continental Tanzania,
Tanzania is located on the African continent between Lake Tanganyika and the
Indian ocean Zanzibar is an archipelago on the same ocean formed by several
islands and islands.
You can't talk about Tanzania without talking about the great European explorers
of Africa,
the famous meeting between Henry Stanley and Dr. Livingston took place in the
interior of this very company,
But it was not the first time that European had visited these lands.
The Europeans had already been going to Zanzibar centuries before until the
Sultan of Oman threw them out. At that time,
the Omanis dominated the entire Indian ocean coast from a man to Madagascar.
This was so much of their territory, but in the 18th century,
the Sultan moved his capital from a man to Zanzibar.
The problem was that his children got along worse than Scottish people did with
English ones or Scottish people with American ones or squash people with French
ones.
Basically I'm saying Scottish people are grumpy and saw where the salt tans
kids.
So one branch of the family inherited the salt in it of Zanzibar and probably
cut off ties with our relatives and this way, the Sultan,
it was fully independent for more than three decades until surprise surprise.
The British empire took over by the way,
this CELTA Nate also owned the entire East coast of the African continent.
So you can see why the most important city in Tanzania is called Dar ES Salaam.
It was an exemplary country until a few years ago,
in terms of religious coexistence. Nevertheless,
Christianity still has a strong presence. There sometimes even an exaggerated.
His leader urges people to worship and throngs against Corona virus.
President John Mughal, fooly scorned,
social distancing sees Jesus Christ is antidote to say Titanic virus,
wall street journal. Meanwhile.
Mainland Tanzania,
it was colonized by the Germans and then became a British protectorate.
This was the case until 1961, the year Tanganyika gained independence.
And then two years later in 1963 came the independence of Zanzibar.
But my friends, the situations were very, very different.
Well, Tanganyika was a multi-party Republic during the first year,
Zanzibar returned to the hands of the Sultan and a powerful ruling Arab elite.
However, the independence CELTA nature of Zanzibar lasted only one month.
Our revolution broke out almost immediately deposing the Sultan and founding the
people's Republic of Zanzibar. And as you can imagine,
that people's doesn't exactly always mean freedom.
The country was about to become yet another experiment with communism. However,
it's president Abby pyramid. Although I left when type was more moderate,
he didn't want a communist dictatorship and find the formula to avoid it.
Uniting Zanzibar with Tonga Zika, to form a new country, Tanzania, to do this.
He had to get along with the man considered to be the father of the Tanzania
nation, Julius NARI, a professor, and the architect of African socialism.
Someone who had a very unusual concept of democracy.
Democracy is not a bottle Coca-Cola,
which you can import democracy should develop.
According to that particular country, I never went to a country,
saw a lot of parties and assumed that it is democratic Julius. [inaudible].
Starting point,
as you can perhaps imagine Newbury and to remiss shear to the power,
they reached a clear and simple agreement.
Newberry would be president of Tanzania and Karimi is vice-president.
And addition Karimi would also be the president of Zanzibar,
which was becoming a semi-autonomous region.
That was the pact by my friend's nefarious plans for the new Tanzania didn't end
there. And it must be said,
but the result was not very different from what had been planned for Zanzibar,
but that had come a boat as he promised,
without aligning himself with the Soviet union.
Well, the fact is the African socialism marks Tanzania's first two decades.
Numerai declared a one-party state nationalized companies and factories and
forced 11 million peasants to work on collective farms by force burning their
homes to keep them from returning as is often the case.
When you force people who have no idea what they're doing to work in the fields,
these farms were a complete failure.
The result was a massive famine and despite Tanzania's enormous potential,
there was real economic chaos.
And at that time,
loons from the international monetary fund helped that country get out of the
situation, but as always with a bunk, the fund set conditions,
and for once they didn't ask for anything particularly controversial,
the country basically had to open up to the free market.
This was a change that [inaudible] did not want to accept. So in 1985,
he understood that his team has precedent with over at the age of 63,
he retired and went home. Undoubtedly,
one of the best decisions of his entire political career
It's voluntary departure allowed to changes to come to the country in 1994,
multi-party democracy was restored in Tanzania.
And my friends Tanzania has since become one of Africa's favorite countries for
investors as state control over the economy,
relaxed investment began to rule and Tanzania attracted direct foreign
investment that accounted for 4% of its GDP annually,
not an inconsiderable figure for decades.
The United Kingdom in the United States were the main investors until recently,
of course, when everything changed.
China emerges Tanzania's major investor ventures. Africa.
The point is that regardless of where the money comes from,
all this investment has had consequences.
Tanzania's economic situation has improved and is per capita income has doubled
so far the century, moreover, as you can see in this graph,
Tanzania's annual GDP growth has not stopped increasing.
And over the last 20 years has been about 4% per year,
indeed Tanzania's economy.
It was performing better than that of Sub-Saharan Africa.
And so it seemed that things were slowly getting better and a country that was
perhaps destined to become one of Africa's great hopes and you know what
everything was looking great until Magufuli the current president came to power
because my friends with his arrival, everything changed. Check this out.
The Tanzanian bulldozer.
Mega fooly is known as the bill dozer,
a nickname errands during his time as minister of public works.
But the truth is that this name is also a fitting description of his team as
president. Although in this case for different reasons,
some better and some worse, for example,
he inaugurated his presidency by cracking down on corruption.
He removed 10,000 ghost workers from the public payroll,
Phantom workers who caused the country $2 million every month.
Then another value celebrated move was to integrate an Al Bino into his cabinet.
Since in Africa,
there are many prejudices against albinos and they are persecuted by local
witchdoctors, but friends of visual politics don't get too excited.
That is pretty much the extent of [inaudible] successes.
And his entire five years.
We do.
The president of Tanzania has ruled impulsively without thinking about the
consequences of each of his measures. For example,
first he proposed that secondary education be free,
which may sound at first to be very good. However,
the immediate consequence was problematic as the schools filled up and the
situation got out of control.
It's easy to promise something if you don't have the resources watch out because
the cure can be worse than the disease.
And that is not all the situation of the Tanzania educational system was
definitely affected when Micah fully decreed to the expulsion of all foreign
workers without proper permits at the national level,
this measure expelled thousands of Kenyans who'd been working as teachers.
Therefore the final outcome was doubly terrible, more students,
fewer private and subsidized schools and fewer teachers. In other words,
overcoded classes and poor quality teachers.
[Inaudible].
And then there were his economic measures. For example,
the port of Dar ES Salaam was a gateway to East Africa goods floated through
there, to, and from neighboring countries and the interior of the continent,
such as Malawi or Zambia. Well,
Margaret fooly wanted to take economic advantage of this situation by increasing
the tax burden on all of this trait.
What do you think he achieved in doing so though,
the shipping companies simply changed their trade routes and now use Kenyan
ports more frequently. Unfortunately, this was not the worst measure.
Other economic sectors have not had the opportunity to escape so easily from the
sudden changes.
During the last few years,
any rule of law that provides certain guarantees to investors has completely
disappeared in this country. Let's just say that the abuses of the MegaFood,
the government against foreign companies have been relentless up to the point of
greeting situations like this.
Tanzania has hit a British mining company with a fine worth two centuries of
revenue.
We all know that the exploitation of Africa's natural resources is always a
sensitive issue.
It's delicate because the benefit of all that wealth is hardly ever noticed
locally.
But this time we are talking about a fame to the British company of Acadia,
meaning of no less than hold onto your hats.
$190 billion. That is roughly four, the current GDP of Tanzania. And of course,
some of you may be wondering,
so how on earth did the microfilm government justify cruising on all of those
zeros? Well, according to their calculations,
$40 billion was in arrears and the other 150 billion was an interest.
And the tax penalty itself Acadia was accused of declaring less than 10% of its
gold exports from Tanzania. Of course,
it must be said that the company's response was fantastic.
They told microphilia, let's see,
we would love your accusation to be real since,
and that case we would be exploiting the largest gold mines in the world,
but it is simply not SU. So in the end,
Acadia and Tanzania have agreed to settle this matter for $300 million.
Meanwhile, of course, international investors have already taken notes.
Yeah.
Take, for example, the case of the British company, Petra diamonds,
but it's put as diamond mine in Tanzania,
up for sale due to similar accusations of tax evasion,
the new obstacles to foreign investment have even affected interest in projects,
such as the port of Baga Memorial,
a mega project in which the Chinese companies involved and the Omani sovereign
wealth funds have just not been able to reach an agreement with the Tanzania.
Wow.
They must have plenty of capital to put up so many obstacles to foreigners,
right? Basically this is a good example of how dangerous populism can be.
The fact is that the slowdown in investment flows should have had a significant
impact on the Tanzanian economy. However,
the official figures provided by the mega foolish government keep GDP growth
above 5% per year. Of course,
those numbers do not convince international organizations such as the world bank
and the IMF that things have not been going well in this country for a long
time. There is simply no explanation as to how the economy can be growing or tax
revenues and loans to the private sector are falling less technical,
but still very significant figures have also taken a fall such as the sales of
the country's largest brewery. I mean, come on, right? This reeks of it.
Racist.
And then there is the apparently non-existent effects of COVID-19 on the
country's economy.
Microphilia declared months ago that Tanzania was free of Corona virus.
Of course, news. Like this makes us suspect that this is not.
It is no longer a crime to publish statistics in Tanzania, the citizen, Oh.
The international pressure exerted by the world bank has made the mega freely
government reversely approved legislation that made it a crane to publish
unofficial testings. But hold on just one moment,
because even though it is now decriminalized,
the approval of the national statistics office is still needed in order to
publish any unofficial data. So as you can imagine,
freedom of expression is not a strong point in Tanzania, far from it.
And all this repression has also reached the political opposition.
And what way though? Well, let's take a look at that right now.
The future of Tanzania, Tanzania.
Economic growth.
This is abandoned African socialism and opened up to the free market has had one
key element. So far political stability.
They've never faced a civil war or a military dictatorship.
The country opened up to multi-party politics 25 years ago, since then, however,
the ruling party has been the same as before the multi-party system, Chama chap,
Maputo, Kinsey. And I really hope that's how you see it in Swahili.
Just bear in mind, mispronouncing things is my thing. I'm Scottish.
I barely speak English translated.
It means something along the lanes of the party of the revolution.
And don't ask me what revolution,
because it's the typical party that doesn't want to change anything.
And the most revolutionary thing about it as its name. So at this point,
some of you are probably thinking, all right, let's hold on a minute. It's not,
the Tanzania was very democratic before mega freely,
but the same party has always governed. Right? And yes, yes. Okay.
You're right.
But we are talking about a country with a defective democracy that has turned
into.
This Tanzania arrests, opposition party leader, revokes newspaper license,
Reuters.
Stories like this one from June,
2020 have become commonplace and Tanzania newspaper closures, censorship,
artist, band, and even arrested.
Anyone who moves against mega Philly puts themselves in the bill.
Those are sites. It's the same story in the political arena. For example,
live television coverage of parliamentary debates has been banned.
So that criticism of microfilm is not visible rallies and political
demonstrations have also been banned disappearances of journalists critical or
just even opposed to the government or the order of the day.
And the violence has reached unusual levels.
You only have to look at the case of the opposition candidate for the
presidential elections held on October 28th parliamentarian to-do.
Lisa has spent three years between Kenya and Belgium,
recovering from the serious consequences of the shooting.
He was a victim of a shooting, which by the way,
no one has ever been arrested for.
Although I think by now we can all guess who was behind it.
And that is precisely why he didn't return to Tanzania until last July.
His safety is not guaranteed and that is the main opposition
candidate.
And then there's another outcome. All this oppression has scared away.
International donors reluctant to finance the whims of a president who puts on
airs and graces.
Tanzania now forced to fund its budget as donor aid freeze bites.
Faced with this scenario, it's,
it's difficult to imagine an adverse electoral result for mega fooly five years
ago, he won with 58% of the votes against 40% for the opposition party.
This is the tightest result and Tanzania's short history.
And so it comes down to this,
the fact that it seems impossible for the opposition to have any chance of
winning the election is a real shame.
And there are two reasons for this because political alternation is good for
consolidating a democracy,
especially when [inaudible] has been in power for as long as Tanzania has
existed. And secondly, because there is a viable alternative,
the opposition led by [inaudible] has not become radical,
has not become a party desperate for the domination of JAMA jam.
Quinsy are eager for revenge on the contrary. In fact,
they appear to want to follow the example of Abby Amad and Ethiopia.
Kadimah aims to fight corruption,
defending moderate center rate approaches and a more liberal economic model.
Something that let's face. It would be very attractive to investors.
And secondly, given what I have seen and the way things are,
could be quite good for the country on one moment,
because if the opposition is having a hard time in Tanzania,
there are even worse off in Zanzibar.
You see Zanzibar has been in a deep crisis since the result of the regional
elections was a Nolde five years ago. When everything pointed to the opposition,
winning the violent regression suffered by the opposition supporters carried out
by pro government malicious Nunez. The zombies is radicalizing the situation,
the civic United front,
a moderate party once aspiring to cool governed Tanzania with the dominant force
in tanking,
Nika is being pushed to defend the right for self-determination of the Zanzibar.
I'll have to wait and see what happens with the election results,
but the discontent of the local population is increasing.
And don't forget that we are talking about a mostly young Muslim population with
growing unemployment due to the decline in tourism,
in the face of the pandemic and a population who are already oppressed by the
Tanzanian authorities and short here,
we have all of the elements necessary for Islamist extremism to prosper.
And the truth is my friends. We said at the start, we like to be optimistic.
We don't like having to bring up all these things about Tanzania,
which is surely a wonderful country with the Serengeti and Mount Kilimanjaro.
So microphilia would do well to tune down his authoritarianism before turning a
country that had been taking the right steps towards the future and to an
isolated, pure Tanzania that is more like his personal country estate.
But now it's your turn and today's questions are key.
Did you think there should be stronger international pressure on such presidents
or do you think it is better not to meddle in another countries,
internal affairs and most importantly,
will there ever be an episode where I pronounce all of the names correctly?
Leave your answer in the comments. Have you find this video interesting.
Don't forget to give us a like and subscribe to visual politic if you haven't
done so already. And if you haven't, what are you doing with your life?
Take care. We'll see you next time.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice from check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play,
or your favorite pod catcher.